I think I can sum up the show for you
with one word,
nothing,
nothing.
What does that mean?
It wasn't until episode three of season
four that Seinfeld gave itself that
famous description as a show about
nothing,
not until this episode called the pitch,
which mock documents Jerry and Larry
David's first meeting with NBC
executives.
Nothing happens on the shelf,
just like life.
The interview since then like this,
Reddit Ama from 2014,
the creators admit that the moniker was
only really a joke and that they were
actually surprised by how much it caught
on with audiences and yet I think the
nothing in question is a good lens to
examine this show through to explore
what makes it different from other
sitcoms and so popular still today.
And when you think of Seinfeld,
the first thing that pops into your head
probably isn't 19th century French
novelist gustave flow bear,
but there's a connection here that I
think is worth exploring a little bit.
So you bear was a pioneer of literary
realism in large part,
responsible for raising the status of
the novel to that have a high art so
intense with his dedication to craft
that in a letter to Luis call a in
January 18,
52,
he wrote what seems beautiful to me.
What I should like to write is a book
about nothing,
a book dependent on nothing external
held together by the internal strength
of its style.
Now,
of course,
a novel like Madame bovary isn't
literally about nothing.
The book explores themes of freedom,
love,
and Human Stupidity,
and explores them deeply the differences
that flow bear.
Instead of getting at these themes
through subject and plot like his
predecessors treats them with style.
He doesn't just want to string you along
with multiple suspense,
heightening narrative developments.
He wants to bring you into the text
itself to look there for the carefully
constructed meanings that he's built for
you.
So in full bear says he wants to write a
book about nothing.
What he really means is nothing like the
established forms and genres against
which he situated himself.
Indeed,
in any art form,
the positive value of a work in question
has to be determined against or in
negative relation to the other kinds of
work already present in the form.
By the 19 fifties and number of
conventions for the television Sitcom
had already been established.
Family had become the dominant setting
for the situation comedy.
These sitcoms feature predominantly
white middle class families,
sometimes with kids sometimes without
dealing comedically with a problem of
the week before resolving the issue and
coming together into a kind of unity so
that they could do the same thing again
next week.
We sure are.
Come on.
Sugar.
What time of the Mary Tyler Moore Show?
In the 19 seventies,
the nuclear family had been partly
supplanted by the family,
but the sentimental unity of the group
was an even stronger value.
Thank you for being my with cheers.
In the eighties,
Sitcom began to break from.
It's by then state conventions.
There was less sentimentality,
less less than learning and the
transition from family as family or
family as coworkers to family as
friends,
and yet still there was a drive toward
unity,
namely and cheers.
The Romantic unity between Sam and
Diane,
which gave the show a familiar dramatic
weight.
Okay,
okay.
Okay.
I got it.
You run an antique store and people come
into the store and you get involved in
their lives.
What person who runs an antique store
gets involved in people's lives,
so someone comes in to buy an old lamp
and suddenly I'm getting them out of a
jam.
Wasn't until
I felt that the conventions of the
Sitcom work deconstructed fully when all
forms of unity,
familial and especially romantic,
were whole heartedly abandoned for
Seinfeld.
These additional elements,
we're just so much fluff.
Well,
forget the store.
They to have a story.
He says,
you got to have a store
like flow bears,
novels.
Seinfeld for goes the traditional
subject matter of the Sitcom.
It's didactic.
Sentimentality centered around a family
of one kind or another in favor of
stories held together by the internal
strength of its comedy.
Now,
this isn't to say that Seinfeld doesn't
have plots.
It he seinfeld plots are among the most
sophisticated of the genre,
but the plot drivers are different from
it's predecessors.
Instead of goal oriented principle
characters achieving their ends based on
actions that they take.
Seinfeld frequently has its characters.
Make some small action on a whim at the
start of it
episode,
certain cast member of melrose place.
Really have you ever seen the show know,
then spend the rest of the half hour.
We're dealing with the unintended
consequences of that action.
Kimberly's steel Joe's,
and if they do set out to achieve
a goal,
even if they get turned on,
they often fail in the end because of
circumstances beyond their means.
Can I be expected to have the same
expertise as people who own this
equipment in Seinfeld?
More complicated narrative.
Small events from one character's life
can determine outcomes in another.
Any action that any character takes has
unexpected consequences,
so that coincidence,
merely a device in traditional goal
oriented sitcoms becomes the rule on
Seinfeld.
That's the guy officer
Larry.
David's no hugs,
no learning policy for Seinfeld is in
keeping with the show based on refusals,
refusal to entertain sentimental
endings,
real Rome,
hence of any kind or the redemptive
power of the family.
And in doing so,
David and Seinfeld rejected the silently
agreed upon moral standards that guided
every other sitcom to it's weekly
resolutions.
Again,
like madame bovary,
Seinfeld isn't literally about nothing,
but instead of reinforcing larger moral
standards,
it explored insanely minute social
norms.
The women know about shrinkage.
What do you mean like laundry?
Interestingly,
hilariously,
it turns out that while the morals of
past decades have shifted and changed
under our feet,
these petty behavioral questions about
nothing,
all that important proved to be more
timeless and timelessly funny than just
about everything else.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
Obviously I'm a huge Seinfeld fan,
so getting to watch a lot of seinfeld
episodes to make this video was a blast.
I'm also getting to read a lot of flow
bear because I'm a huge fan as well.
And I like to say the word below bear.
Um,
I want to thank you guys so much because
after a couple of weeks ago,
uh,
my video on Harry Potter,
I mentioned how important small pledges
on my patrion where,
because of the length of time is more
important than,
than,
than the amounts.
And that is because it helps me plan on
this channel what I'm going to do next,
what's coming.
And after that video,
a lot of you guys pledged a dollar or $3
and you're awesome for that.
So thank you.
Thank you.
We just crossed 250,000
subscribers on this channel,
which is a quarter million and met some
number that I can't really conceive.
So I am grateful and that's the feeling
that I'm going to keep putting out into
the world.
Um,
so thank you so much for that.
If you want to pledge to my channel,
you can go right here and click there
and I will see you guys next one state
for another video.
This is so much fun.